Now, that you've seen
the WeatherEntry class for
the weather table, it's your turn.
Add the constants for
the location table in the LocationEntry
inner contract class.
These constants included the table name,
and the name of each column.
As we've shown in a few previous
diagrams, the columns need to store
the location setting, latitude,
longitude, and the city name.
After you finish coding
the location entry class,
make sure to look at the solution video.
You'll want to use the same constant
names that we use, since the code in
the other classes you received relies
on these constant names being the same.
Once you've finished,
you will have defined all of
the columns for both of the tables.
Next, we'll be ready to use these column
names to actually create the tables
in the database.